wardrobe that was too outlandish for
Prince communicating in a secret
language and a cameo from a 90210 icon
there's a lot to process with Luke
basson's cult classic The Fifth Element
so forgive yourself for not noticing a
few things on your first
viewing the fifth element has a truly
star studded cast it's not every day you
see people like Bruce Willis Mila yovich
Ian Holm and Gary Oldman all sharing the
screen even the movie smaller characters
are played by excellent actors like
Brian James and Tom lster Jr and then of
course there's Chris Tucker's character
Ruby Rod the first time you watch the
movie it's easy to be so Star Struck
that you actually miss one or two big
stars who get featured on a second pass
though you'll notice that even extremely
minor characters are played by
recognizable actors there's a reason for
instance why Billy looks so familiar in
the beginning of the movie Billy is a
research assistant who witnesses aliens
landing on Earth in 1914 he's got a very
small part to play in the movie which is
a little strange considering he's played
by Luke Perry by 1997 Perry was an
established star with 7even years of
Beverly Hills 90210 and plenty of other
roles under his belt Perry is the kind
of actor who regularly showed up in
unexpected places but even when he
doesn't have that much to do in a movie
he brings a certain level of charm to a
character at its heart The Fifth Element
is an adventure story Corbin's chance
encounter with lelu sends his life
spiraling in a New Direction and the two
of them end up racing across deep space
to save the universe from Evil the movie
introduces some dazzling locations and
sci-fi Concepts but it doesn't spend
nearly as much time developing them as
it does rushing through the plot that's
why every time you rewatch the movie
you'll notice new small details about
the world and sometimes they're a little
concerning by the end of the movie we
don't know all that much about New York
City Circa
2263 but we've gotten enough details to
learn that the city is a borderline
dystopia Corbin's Life as a taxi driver
gives us a glimpse into the capitalist
nightmare that seems to have taken over
this version of the future and his Chase
with the police lets us know that New
York really needs to consider some
drastic reform measures as Corbin's taxi
races passed a police hover car early in
the movie we see that the NYPD of 2263
wears full metal body armor at all times
even if they're at a fast food
drive-thru when the police start to
pursue Corbin it quickly becomes clear
that collateral damage isn't a concern
for them they all but tear apart the
city trying to get Corbin and they don't
even
succeed when lelu lands in the back of
Corbin's taxi she doesn't know where she
is and she definitely doesn't know how
to speak
[Music]
English yeah I understand boom
considering that she's just been
essentially resurrected and brought into
the future from thousands of years in
the past she learns how to communicate
remarkably quickly though she picks up
more and more English as the movie
progresses most of the time lelu speaks
a language Beyond anyone's comprehension
in reality the words that lelu speaks
were created by director Luke bassan
just for this movie
bassan spent 15 years developing the
world of The Fifth Element and in all
that time he also spent some effort
creating a dictionary for the Divine
language bassan invented around 400
words so that lelu could in theory say
everything she needs to say through the
entire movie in a real language bassan
and Mila yovich both became so fluent in
the Divine language that they even used
it to communicate with each other while
filming The Fifth Element gets more
mileage than most movies out of playing
with tropes and character archetypes the
story has a traditional big evil and a
Chosen One destined to defeat it Lelo
and Corbin both get to play out
different takes on the hero archetype
while Gary Oldman zorg stands in for the
movie's real villain the movie sets up a
story that's initially familiar but it
subverts the usual formula whenever it
can one of the oddest Parts about the
fifth element is that the heroes and the
villains never actually see each other
face to face obviously the big space
evil is a kind of amorphous entity that
would probably have trouble standing on
the surface of Earth but Corbin never
even meets zor the Evil's human
representative while lelu only runs into
him briefly but that doesn't mean they
have no connection to him whatsoever the
first time they watch the movie most
people probably miss a small detail on
Corbin's termination notice after he
loses his job zorg owns the company that
fires Corbin so even though the two
never directly meet their conflict is
still
personal according to the Fifth Element
by 2263 Humanity will have spread out to
the stars and made contact with alien
civilizations the future looks and
sounds amazing but when you really think
about the people who are in charge of
the planet you might have second
thoughts about that my philosophy Mr
President is shoot first and ask
questions later I don't like uninvited
guests Earth's military has a big role
to play in The Fifth Element they're the
ones who make first contact with the
great evil that employ zorc and they
eventually help send Corbin and lelu on
their journey to save the world it might
be fair to say all's well that ends well
but the movie shows us over and over
again how incompetent the future
leadership of Earth really is the
president played by Tom tiny list Jr
never seems to have any idea what's
really going on he's willing to take
advice from Ian Holmes Cornelius despite
having very little evidence that the
priest knows what he's talking about
when it comes to Epic space evils the
military on the other hand is
represented by Brian james' character
General Monroe you'd want a general to
have a sound tactical mind but Corbin
manages to outsmart Monroe leaving him
trapped in a freezer in his apartment
while he escapes with lelu the movie is
definitely saying something about people
in power but it's also depicting a
future we all be better off
avoiding the fifth element is filled
with great performances but Chris
Tucker's appearance as Ruby Rod is one
of the most memorable parts of the
entire movie from clothing to hair Ruby
sense of style is something that you
won't forget after seeing it Tucker
brings a tremendous amount of energy to
the role helping Ruby steal scen so
thoroughly that even the characters in
the movie seemed to be a bit stunned by
Tucker's performance it turns out that
everyone on set probably was just as
surprised by Tucker as anyone who's ever
watched The Fifth Element Tucker told e
W that when he took the part hardly
anyone knew what the role was supposed
to be including himself all he knew was
that Prince was supposed to play the
role but he passed it up because the
costumes were too outlandish Tucker
didn't know what to think until he saw
the costume for himself he said I was
kind of like woof this is a deep deep
character but all that stuff really
helped me get into
character Gary Oldman is one of the
greatest character actors of his
generation he's played some heroic
characters but Oldman really shines as a
villain whether he's playing a sh
shifting vampire in brm Stoker's Dracula
or the crazed mayor of a
post-apocalyptic town in the Book of Eli
Oldman brings a chilling energy to all
his baddies amidst all the aliens and
shiny scenery it can be easy to lose
track of oldman's character zorg in The
Fifth Element but the second time
through you'll realize how terrifying he
really is what makes zorg so scary isn't
that he's working for a terrible evil
but that communicating with his evil
boss seems to shake zorg to his very
core on the phone with the evil entity
zorg's head spontaneously starts
bleeding and his own terror is very
apparent despite his fear he keeps
trying to help the evil grow in power
oldman's performance in the movie is
even more impressive if you know the
context surrounding it in an interview
with ro recall the actor admitted that
he only took the role as a favor to Luke
bassan he didn't even read the script
before agreeing to be in the movie and
it doesn't sound like he's a huge fan of
the finished product when told that the
fifth element has become a cult classic
Oldman just laughed and said that's the
wacky world we live in
as a character lelu is obviously based
on Chosen One tropes that are as old as
time itself the movie repeatedly says
that she's supposed to be a perfect
being it's not just that lelu is
destined to save the world but also that
she has some borderline magical
abilities she's an incredibly fast
learner and all but a champion fighter
with little to no training whatsoever
Corbin plays a central role in the story
but it's really lelu who's the hero of
the Fifth Element as much as she's based
on mythological heroes from stories that
came before her Le has also gone on to
inspire other sci-fi Heroes her
influence can easily be seen in
characters like River from Firefly and
serenity but she has a very particular
similarity with another major 90s sci-fi
chosen one in the movie lelu learns how
to fight by watching video feeds on a
small screen she basically downloads the
knowledge into her head 2 years after
the debut of The Fifth Element Neo
learns his own fighting techniques using
a very similar method in The
Matrix I know Kung Fu there are plenty
of 90 Sci-Fi movies that don't hold up
visually today CGI has come a long way
in the past three decades and movies
that went all in on the technology back
then are really starting to show their
age the fifth element has no shortage of
special effects but the movie still
looks fantastic today because so much of
what happens on screen was created
practically Luke bassan knew that his
movie was going to demand an excessive
amount of visual effects it took more
than 160 people to create the 220 shots
that made it into the movie and the team
filmed plenty more that didn't survive
the editing room bassan employed model
makers and artists to make his world as
realistic as possible the spaceships
shown in the movie Are Real Models so is
Corbin's taxi and even some of the New
York city streets that he flies it down
a second viewing gives one plenty of
time to really appreciate the level of
effort that went into making The Fifth
Element as visually engaging as it is
unfortunately not everything that you
notice about The Fifth Element when
watching it again is good there are
plenty of things to praise about the
movie from the performances to the music
to the visual effects but decades later
it also stands out for being filled to
the brim with misogynous stereotypes
there's no way around it the Fifth
Element does a terrible job depicting
women lelu is basically the only human
woman on screen the entire movie and
even though she's a hardcore Action Hero
she still ends up falling into the
damsel and distress role more than once
as badass as lelu may be on her own the
movie doesn't let her be a hero without
the help of Corbin but she's more
fragile than she SE seems she needs your
help and your love she's also wearing
little more than some strategically
placed bandages for the first third of
the film it's the other women in the
movie that get a really problematic
portrayal Corbin's mother and ex-wife
heard only his voices talking to Corbin
over the phone are depicted as greedy
nags who won't let Corbin live his life
in peace the movie plays these moments
for Laughs as Corbin rolls his eyes and
desperately tries to avoid interacting
with them as much as possible those
cringeworthy moments don't ruin the film
by any means but they may tarnish your
memories of it on that second
viewing